[Music]
all right so we know that Tesla's been
taking the world by storm right they
first came out and then a lot of
carmakers are like electric that's
[ __ ] and now every single car maker
is trying to catch up to make electric
cars losers which is pretty crazy
because now the Tesla sort of changed
the game
but now not by Tesla or Elon Musk the
world's largest electric plane takes its
first 28-minute first flight Oh Oh slow
you don't even know maybe they're just
testing it
you think he went eight miles per hour
good look that's a wing shoe LED New
York 28 minutes [ __ ] down oh [ __ ]
yeah I just pictured me who was if it
didn't one of it did that fast
Elliot of New York but your chances of
dying are like now 50% nah yeah I'm
definitely yeah yeah regular do you like
the idea of an electric plank is like
the one thing that I don't know why but
TIFF always books the [ __ ] our seats
are right at the back where the [ __ ]
engines at and here's a book and I'm
late all the front ones I felt that I
see bad looks to me too electric one
though
is it loud think you'd be better yeah
everyone be sleeping I don't know how
loud it is but what they do is I've you
guys heard of Cessnas you're like
private planes sounds like they're just
trying to sound like real like Tesla
where it says like
so they took the Cessna Caravan to 8b
and they use it in a it's a
collaboration between them and this
engine company called magnet X and
what's pretty crazy is since this is the
first electric plane all they have to do
is keep working at it and this could
revolutionize the entire flight industry
which is perfect timing because no one's
really taking flights right now so I
think it's forcing a lot of the bigger
airplane companies to go oh [ __ ] who are
these new guys coming around town
because they just stopped using oil yeah
cuz it could drastically affect the
flight prices which is cool
mm-hmm which is pretty nuts Cheryl I
feel it's expensive oh yeah but damn how
do you like I get that I feel like it
just would take so long to charge up
right come on Tesla stick along not that
long I thought they're pretty quick so
if you have the regular charging thing I
think it takes I think maybe three hours
I mean if you go to one of those Tesla
charging stations they're like 30
minutes for reality five minutes so in
30 minutes for a car like how much for a
plane yeah well maybe they get swapped
about the battery yeah like uh like they
come in and it's like a pit stop but
then the battery comes out that's what
the Tesla like that I don't know what
they call that one like a super super
star a charging station they what
happens you drive on this thing and then
it enters like the autopilot so it knows
what to do and all these things come out
where they go and unscrew your car all
robotics right yeah replaced the battery
with a brand new battery and the Titans
everything back to its factory spec the
Tesla like charging station so it's like
like a car wash you drive into it and
just like hey stop in there and that's
like this is dooby-doo doors and then
any dry path you could do to changes in
the time that it takes to fill up you're
a regular take a cast that's a that's
fast this is the exist right now
yeah if you look it up you'll find a
video a he did like the whole
demonstration but you were scared of how
people can hack into your car like and
like [ __ ] with it and like make it crash
and stuff because it's connected to like
Bluetooth and satellites and [ __ ] I mean
now I never was
no I am it happens
I heard assassinate with this yeah what
you're in a Tahoe I'm mark Tahoe's oh he
got in a car crash yeah they hack let go
your OnStar and they that's how they
assassinate some like dignitaries and
politicians and stuff in a car crash
wait so how does the take control they
can already take control point so the
car itself starts tearing our and so so
the minute yeah so the minute your car
which almost all cars these days have a
two-way communication hmm they can
already find a way to hijack the car
hey deer and it might make it break or
just like turn it off however they need
to crash your P does change the station
it breaks Wow I guess I guess like you
know depending on how much you hack the
[ __ ] you could do that because I
remember like my boy who was good at
like hacking people he could literally
he could make your like CD drive open up
from your from his computer
I would just make like a certain song
keep coming on Oh God on your end you
like Gavin that's capable for the other
than just late with the phone yeah
[ __ ] CD give me a broken week story's
gonna be doing other [ __ ] yeah like this
I'm saying like this was back in like
high school that's why if I was a ghost
I would just [ __ ] with people oh I would
definitely [ __ ] with people only your
friends on hacker goes yeah just be like
opening your [ __ ] like whenever people
leave comments telling me to kill myself
on the Internet I say yeah all right but
I'm gonna [ __ ] haunt you bro I'm
gonna [ __ ] like cuz you'll know yeah
I love it put my finger in your maybe
that's the closest they could ever be to
you so they just like like it guys
saying that will they get more in
trouble then you say yeah I'm gonna
molest you whatever those like fake say
that if you're a ghost imma molest you
like are you still part of the me to
move I'm gonna ghost will this I
wouldn't say I would ghost molest
somebody give a new meaning to depends
on what the ghost community things about
alright cross over to the other side to
figure that the ghost public the court
of public opinion you might have to
ghost them yeah
hey Bert because I don't know what these
people are saying it's not my article no
I was just thinking about it like if a
Kevin Spacey died if people would be sad
now I don't know let people might be
like good riddance really you don't need
people like I was too hard on them Tony
would be like good riddance I think I
think most people would be like good
riddance when someone that is is
cancelled guys yeah yeah like if Bill
Cosby died they would be sick oh they
would be like good riddance well that'd
be good be it would be people wants both
sides
imagine being from the past and you like
in your now we go back in time when were
like yeah Bill Cosby's dead and you'd be
like what that's crazy
any but not good and yeah that's true
right and the people that didn't find
out what he did yeah well I don't know
you think about look at Michael Jackson
when he passed away like everyone was
mourning because Michael do [ __ ] help me
yeah but before before in my way he's
always carried the stigma and people
were always kind of like I don't know
man Michael was kind of you know Michael
wacko Jack we don't push me like we did
now though yeah let's say Michael and
it's great because people were like oh
you wouldn't thank god he's back now
Michael Kennedy did oh sure sure I think
it's way different if you're you know if
you were alleged yeah yes yeah because
that's like there's a difference between
what's his name is tamir max every
Wednesday he's going to jail he's like I
think everybody wants him like if he
died they're like great isn't he already
in jail he's already in jail boy but
then they removed him to a different
part when kovat happened because i guess
he got kovat or something didn't his
health is deteriorating he's like ah
yeah he's for sure faking that he looks
in bad he wants pity yeah he probably
just had his like make up movie magic
friends come make him up to look call
shitty and sick so he can get some
sympathy you know yeah yeah the corona
was a way to hide the whole Epstein
think I like a distraction like a big
distraction there's so many so many
conspiracy theories yeah cuz if Epstein
was alive and calm on the trap [ __ ]
ratted it's almost so many world leaders
over the celebrities CEOs we're gonna
know who out of all the but like all of
the leaders was a molester mmm who
[ __ ] like teen girls and all that [ __ ]
oh I don't think they needed korone I
think he just killed him that's all
no they didn't need to start like a
whole but then also what after he died
there's all these things coming out like
oh [ __ ] it's an inside job and I think
it was creating more of a mystery so it
raises more questions I think was dying
down though people don't before Crona
happened should be manner he came out
there doctor I just came on now just in
time for Khurana I know I can't wait to
watch it it's not even being talked
about like Joey's like went crazier than
this yeah I mean jeez yes John they just
vicodin blood do you have photos and
nobody gives a [ __ ] I know right crazy
no one gives a [ __ ] about the UFO people
like Tiger King oh yeah okay you know
they're working on a scripted version ya
know but how can they make it more
interesting than that
like real is better than yeah it was way
better here's what they're gonna do is
they're gonna just they're gonna play up
the funny part of it I feel you know st.
comedy cuz you have all these crazy
characters already got so heightened in
real life there's like how much more
heightened could you get and now you can
add like dialog like we're just
ridiculous situations that's how much
they had a cut out of that true it's
probably crazy you're and there's still
a document over there how to form a
story to where like yeah oh because I'm
imagining things right so you know the
Carroll Baskin part there's a part where
they start diving more and more into her
world right and then there's already
people there like I've been volunteering
for five years how about you yeah a
little bit you wear a blue shirt already
yellow shirt on my that world is already
saw [ __ ] ridiculous how do you
heighten the world like that well here's
the thing now that they have the rights
to it they can they can go wherever they
want with it you know I'm saying they
can add [ __ ] extra Tiger
horseshit the dope thing is like Joe's
eyes like yeah if I can make it crazier
guess who's playing too exotic is what I
heard Nicolas Cage no they should have
had the Joe Dirt he does look like I
think it's gonna be dope
Channing Tatum I can kind of see a
renown I won one but I thought I think
the reality is what makes ya good
because everyone's intentions are pure
and this is how crazy they really are
yeah the rat at the end the guy on the
[ __ ] the jet ski oh my god that show
was scripted this Chef big and Python
believable but the fact that it was real
it was like so much more way better
because if imagine if it was scripted
right we go over the top right you are I
too hard what is this a sketch show
mm-hmm yeah because it's real I think
that's where the magic is man and now we
can watch the script you want to be like
oh yeah oh oh oh they're doing the thing
just like in the real thing that that
role should have been played by what's
his face from eastbound in town because
Brian would have been over quick in that
role Danny McBride the guy in a tropic
thunder where he wants to blow
everything up explicitly or a pie now
all the older guys yeah he has a good
yeah yeah okay nice a little too big now
yeah you can lose some weight but he
he's got the right type like the right
brand who's the other character that
plays the eastbound and down no those
cannon powers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]